- [Mark] All right, Ryan,
- yes sir.
- [Mark] Ryan Where you
from, Where'd you grow up?
- New Orleans born in the city zoo,
which is Charity Hospital in the 70s.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood
you were with both parents
when you were a kid.
I, for the most part
they're both drug addicts.
Dad was a real bad alcoholic.
My mother was poly substance abuse.
You know, she did a
lot of different drugs.
I was born addicted to methadone
and heroin, alcohol, for sure.
I was really sick as a child.
I was in an oxygen tank
for about six months
when I was born, because
my lungs collapsed.
I had celiac disease, and
also I had real bad colic.
And I was so it was so bad that my mom
would actually beat me because I was sick.
And my grandmother would have
to come and get me in fear of
my mom gonna kill me, you know?
And she would literally bring
me to my grandmother's house
coz she was scared she was
gonna kill me. You know,
so, but yeah, childhood
wasn't all that great.
In the beginning,
but as I started to get a
little bit better childhood
was very dysfunctional by far.
You know, we always had a
lot of people at the house.
My dad being a biker,
from the galloping goose's
and you know, and hanging
out with a lot of people
from big organizations, you know.
- [Mark] And you're how far in school?
I made to sixth grade.
- [Mark] Sixth grade?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Where'd you go, I
mean, why'd you stop there?
- I'm just getting
Well, I'll tell you what happened was,
I accidentally shot my friend
around that time, and it
was just when I was starting
to come out of my shell as
not being very sociable,
but when I shot my friend, it wind up,
killing everything that
I had built in school,
so I became an outcast and
nobody liked me anymore,
because I shot a friend of everybody's,
and a very good friend
of mines in my house
with a 22 long range rifle,
it was an accident, in a sense,
because I forgot that when
you put the clip in the gun
that it loads one of the
chamber people arrived back,
so I shot him and he almost
hit his femoral artery
and he almost died.
you know, so I just quit school
and when I'm on you know thing
really closed in became real.
Almost a hermit for quite a long time.
You know, and started to I was
already kind of doing drugs.
You know, huffing different
Freon and scotch guard
and smoking marijuana
I did some pain pills
and snorting coke and did
acid and did pretty much
the full gamut except for would wind up
becoming my main drug being heroin.
But yeah, it was pretty quick start
to my whole addicted lifestyle,
- [Mark] Did the guilt you felt
about shooting your friend?
- Well, of course, I had to, you know,
I felt like I had to do the job
that's the reality to cope
with everyday existence.
You know, I had a girlfriend
at the time when I shot him
and I went to jail for quite
a few weeks after shot him
in juvenile jail and you
know, I was really, really,
this was my first love,
and I love this so much.
And she stuck with me through it.
But, you know, when I got
out, it was a big fiasco
because my mom and dad was
getting divorced at the time.
And my father kept the phone
and everything all my
phone calls from my mother
and all kinds of it was
just, it was terrible.
waiting outside with rifles in her bushes,
gonna kill her husband, her.
We had to go get him
out of mental hospitals.
It was really bad you know,
and at the same time,
I had to look out for my
little sister, you know,
and that's what really mattered
to me the most at that time,
was making sure she didn't
get involved in everything
that was going on.
- [Mark] He died?
- No, no, he has any now
he's one of my best friends.
I mean, we're back friends
and you know, he's a great brother.
And he wasn't never supposed to have kids
he wanted to have five of them.
He's married to a good friend of ours,
and he works offshore, and
he's always a real good friend
of me even to this day.
You know, he checks up on me on Facebook,
when he sees I'm active
when I got a phone you know,
like all everybody on
my Facebook is mostly,
like people that I grew up with, you know.
- [Mark] So today you live
where you're on the street?
- I'm on the streets,
I've been on the streets
quite some time now.
I've done a lot of time
in prison you know,
I'm 27 years out of my 43 years on Earth.
I've been in prison,
- [Mark] what kind of convictions?
- Most of my convictions are drug related.
If it's not a drug offense,
it'd be shoplifting
or grand larceny, the negligent
injury and temper homicide
and some other things but
nothing no sex offenses
and nothing like that. You know,
just basically everything that had to do
with obtaining the drugs.
- [Mark] Yeah. So what would
you do for money today?
- Today? anything I you know,
I mean, I've done it all
from prostitution escort
to robbery to stealing
to everything, you know,
- [Mark] Prostitution meaning?
- Oh yeah, I've been a prostitute,
Yeah in quite a few cities
in quite a few cities
quite a few of (indistinct)
the gay scene that was really popular
at the time Christopher street in New York
when it was around Prospect Park,
the time and it was really popular.
HIV is running rapid.
I'm in Hollywood here on
Santa Monica Boulevard.
I worked for one of the
biggest escort companies
in Houston, Texas
quarterback entertainment,
I did a lot of escorting.
I danced at the corner pocket
when I was really young,
like 17, which is a
gay bar in New Orleans,
that lets underage kids
dance there, you know?
You know, and then I
prostituted in New Orleans
quite a while, you know, with
the little strip, you
know where everybody is
- [Mark] Are you gay?
- I'm not I well,
I identify my sexual
preferences money, basically.
But I mean, I was transgender
for almost 10 years, you know,
but I also have, you know,
baby Mamas and you know,
I'm saying,
- [Mark] Are you saying you have children?
- Yeah,
- [Mark] How many kids do you have?
- I got Well, I think I had three.
Yeah, my son I actually know his mind.
But it did, which is a
whole story unto itself
Me and his mother were best
friends since we were kids.
And she came with me
to Hollywood on a whim.
On her 18th birthday, I
went to a concert with her
at Marilyn Manson on Canal
Street in New Orleans
and sold a bunch of fake ecstasy
to get enough money for
us to go to Hollywood.
She came with me and nine months later,
after she left me, she had a baby,
which he just graduated from
high school, and he's awesome.
He's a friend of mine in Facebook,
and I've been around him his whole life,
but his mother's never told me his mind.
And he don't know.
And I know he is I can just look at him.
- [Mark] You communicate
with him through Facebook?
- Yes, all the time.
- [Mark] But have you
spend time with him at all?
- No, like, I'm you know,
I've been out here quite a while
quite a lot since he's been born.
And I've also been in prison a lot so,
this is the longest I've ever
been out of prison in my life.
I've never had a run this long,
which is going on about
two and a half years now.
Where I've not, you know,
usually my whole life
has been 30 days out 20
days out there, you know,
a year here a year there.
- [Mark] Do you think that's
because you're in LA now
where the cops might be
a little more lenient?
- No, I think it was even in New Orleans.
I think it's due to the
revamping of the justice system.
As far as drugs are concerned.
I think they're starting to
recognize that drug disease
is an addiction and it's
like putting somebody
in jail for cancer you know,
we just shaking out of the
Reagan era of the war on drugs,
you know?
- [Mark] Did you have any friends?
- Friends, I'll tell you what?
I have a very small circle
that I would call friends
one being my sister,
and one being not my brother,
but he is my brother.
You know, he's been around
since he found his father
hung on a tree Christmas morning,
and he's been around us ever since
he's just one of my greatest,
you know, people in my life.
You know, Jerome, good
friend of mine, you know,
that's it, though.
Other than that, it's just acquaintances.
You know, you try not to
let anybody in too deeply
because I've suffered enough pain man,
I've been through so
many traumatic, you know,
being molested as a child.
I've been, you know, raped in prison.
See, I'm still trying to figure this out.
I actually confronted my mother with this,
when I've seen it this time
and it was a guy on my street.
I remember his name
being Doug he was older
and it was when I was very, very young.
You know, so
that's the only thing I can remember.
- [Mark] Tell me about
the tattoos on your Face?
- well, my brother who
died in jail, on a toilet
from septic houses, he bled out.
And they didn't find his
body to the next morning.
His daughter is Elena.
And now she's my niece
and a lovely Jasmine.
She's such a sweet girl and
she's always never judged me.
You know, she's always loved
the (indistinct) for who he is,
you know? And this tattoo.
- [Mark] Can you turn your face this way?
- Yeah, this tattoo the cross represents
a lot of different things.
But mostly it's broken
because of the brokenness
that religion has done me.
You know, I believe now I
know for a fact. You know,
I'm educating myself I mean,
even though I graduated
With a sixth grade now I had two degrees.
And I went to a biology
school and a lot of, you know,
degree in behavioral science and
but it just represents that brokenness
of religion had scarred me over the years.
But the guy that did these tattoos,
we grew up together essentially
young in New Orleans,
he died two days at the dorm.
He od on fentanyl in the tattoo shop.
And, he was in the bathroom.
I wasn't there at the time,
and they wouldn't kick the door down
without permission of the owners
and they knew he was dead.
So I kind of got a
conspiracy theory about that.
But, you know, he's a good friend of mine.
And, you know, he's now gone,
because, you know, this
terrible opioid addiction.
And, you know, that's
going on across the country
in Louisiana, and New Orleans, especially
has the highest opioid
addiction rate per capita
in the world,
- [Mark] Is that right?
- yeah.
So you know,
- [Mark] what's the most
important lesson you've learned?
How old are you?
- I'm 43? Yeah,
- [Mark] what's the most
important lesson you've learned
in your 43 years?
- The most important lesson I learned is,
the most important thing to
me is just being a good person
to people that I don't know,
instead of people that I know,
I gotta be good to, I need
to be good to the people
that are necessarily wouldn't
be good to any other time,
you know, otherwise
Because I see how different
people work in different lives.
And I see how good things that
you do produce good fruit.
You know, karma is real, you know,
and it comes around, you know,
you know, it's really,
really a real thing you know,
especially on the streets, you know.
- [Mark] All right, Ryan.
Well, thank you so much
for talking with me.
Very interesting story.
And good luck out there.
- You're welcome.
- [Mark] Thank you.
- Thank you.